foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI Scarlett heads inside
the houses of Parliament where
politicians Lords and baronesses debate
and vote on big decisions and new laws
and did you know that it's not just
adults who speak in there it's kids like
us too
a new laws to give us more protection
from harmful content online and being
debated by politicians right now but do
they go far enough
[Music]
this is FYI the Weekly News show where
we bring you all the latest info on the
big stories and we investigate possible
fake news
check out this picture that's been doing
the rounds online
apparently this is a new roller coaster
that jumps the track this means the
roller coaster will fly through the air
during part of the ride with no track
underneath it but do you think this is
fun fair fact or fake news we'll reveal
all later
now we're used to adults making the
decisions in the house of parliament
this is where laws and government
policies are debated and voted on but
did you know there's an actual youth
Parliament and anyone from the ages of
11 to 18 can get involved with it and we
went to see some young people from the
British overseas territories speaking
for their first time in Parliament that
they come from 14 different places
across the world that are actually part
of Britain places like the Cayman
Islands Gibraltar Bermuda and Scarlet's
been finding out more
[Music]
order order we now come to lead with the
opposition
the houses of Parliament are made up of
two houses the House of Commons where
politicians from all political parties
debate and vote on things the government
wants to do the government will update
the house
and the House of Lords where Lords and
baronesses vote on what the politicians
want to do and can send back requests
for changes
but what is amazing is we have found out
that there is also a youth Parliament so
we get a say too right in there is the
House of Commons where the young people
are going to be speaking on top of the
agenda is climate change and young
people's mental health we have the worst
mental health rates in the entire UK is
it too much to let the young the working
the elderly suffer my name is charity
and I'm here today to represent the
British Virgin Islands it's just
territories like the British Virgin
Islands whose carbon footprint is almost
non-existent who were the ones that will
now suffer the most from the
environmental challenges the world now
faces
in fact the six months of the year the
threat of an active hurricane season is
always looming over our Shores my name
is Yaya I'm from the Falkland Islands
the Falklands are experiencing a
concerning Trend towards drying land and
increased water scarcity which has
significant risks and impacts Associated
for our society environment and economy
we may not be able to vote we may not be
able to stand as MPS but there are
enough of us and we all have a voice is
climate change not one of the most if
not single-handedly the most important
issue facing the Youth of today I think
it's very important that the youth have
a say in the activities that take place
in Parliament especially decisions that
are made towards our future even though
the features in Saturn I am still
hopeful for even though we are small we
are Mighty thank you
what strikes me is that there could
easily be a future Prime Minister in
that room
[Music]
[Applause]
so something really important is being
debated by politicians in Parliament
right now it's a complicated set of new
laws which have one simple aim to keep
us all safe online
while going online gives us access to
loads of info and we can connect with
each other there's also a lot of
misinformation and harmful content so
the government created a new set of laws
known as The Online safety Bill a set of
ideas that basically police the internet
politicians are about to vote on whether
the bill should become law one of the
ideas in the Online safety bill was to
force big tech companies like YouTube or
Facebook to remove harmful content such
as videos promoting Eating Disorders or
racism we've got hold of the government
Minister overseeing the Online safety
Bill culture secretary Michelle donalan
hi Michelle so what's the latest with
this bill and will harmful content still
have to be removed if a social media
platform they allow illegal images or
illegal stuff to to reach children or
adults then they have to remove it and
if they allow harmful content to reach
children or young people under the age
of 18 they don't remove it they will
face fines but we read that politicians
in the labor party and children
charities say that this will not protect
children the content will still be there
yeah it definitely does rely on the
online company to remove it they will
have a legal duty to do so because of
this bill but I can assure you here
today on FYI that any illegal content
will not be shown for children or adults
and any harmful content will not be
shown to children or young people if
social media companies do that it will
be breaking the bill but aren't you
putting too much trust in these big tech
companies it's a big risk isn't it we're
putting all the owners on those social
media platforms to do everything
themselves they are the ones that can
have to make sure you don't see illegal
content well I can assure you today
Braden is that this bill is now stronger
in its protections for young people and
children so I think we're going to make
history here and we're going to protect
lots of children and young people and
potentially save lives as well thanks
for talking to FYI Michelle
and for more info on how to stay safe
online head to our webpage and check out
our I don't get to explainer at
first.news forward slash FYI
now can you imagine a jungle or a forest
growing in the middle of your city I'm
talking on the streets in airports on
buildings everywhere all to help tackle
climate change well neither could we so
here's Sadie who lives in Singapore with
more on their unique way on how to cool
down the planet
welcome to one of the smallest countries
in the world
this is my home and even though I'm just
an ordinary kid I'm kind of protective
about it
the way I see it there's nowhere else
like this on Earth
its nickname is the city in a garden and
it's easy to see why
but all this Greenery isn't just to look
pretty it's also doing a really
important job
Singapore is one of the hottest places
on the planet so for many years now the
city authorities have been looking for
innovative ways to cool things down
and they've discovered something quite
incredible that the rest of the world
can learn from as our planet heats up
it's not rocket science Singapore's
secret is actually quite simple okay are
you ready here we go
yep simply by planting trees this city
has lowered the air temperature by up to
2 degrees Celsius the trees provide
shade and release cooling water vapor
into the air from their leaves
[Music]
in Singapore we try to live in harmony
with the natural world
this is a major tourist attraction
called Gardens by the bay where you can
take a walk above a canopy of trees even
though some of them are man-made you'll
also find vegetation on lots of
Singapore's buildings including this
eco-friendly Hotel
at the airport where they've got their
own rainforest waterfall
I love it here it's like a high-tech
Tropical Paradise
but even though Singapore has made a
good start with more than half of our
land now covered with trees we know
we've got to do more to tackle climate
change so our government has drawn up
what it calls the green plant so what
will the green plan mean for us well the
green plan is actually trying to turn
Singapore into a city in nature and that
means putting in so many parks in green
spaces such that nobody living in
Singapore is more than 10 minutes walk
away from a place like this if you look
at the bird's eye view of Singapore you
will see a city very busy full of people
but at the same time it's all green it
looks like a jungle and that's what we
aim to do and what are the advantages of
creating more green spaces the
advantages are plentiful Greenery and
nature plants they capture carbon it
cools the planet and the green spaces
also provide living spaces for lots of
interesting animals so these are very
important things but what about all the
buildings in Singapore there's a lot of
concrete right there is a lot of
concrete what Singapore does very well
and is trying to improve on is putting
plants on buildings so even though you
are in the middle of a city many of
these buildings houses and hotels have
vertical Greenery it's not easy to do
but we have tried our very best and I
think we have done very well in doing so
the ball
problem
still uses a lot of air conditioning
units can you see them up there they're
pretty ugly to be honest and they use up
loads of energy the way they work is by
pumping hot air out of buildings that
people work and live in it's not very
eco-friendly
so here's another idea that Singapore is
trying out the city's Engineers say that
down there is one of the largest systems
of its kind in the whole world
an underground network of pipes sending
chilled water through an entire District
the pipes travel through all buildings
helping to cool down the air inside
it will cut down the amount of energy we
use by more than 40 percent as well as
reducing carbon emissions
you can probably tell I'm really quite
proud of my country and everything we're
doing to tackle climate change and at
night the man-made super trees are lit
up in a spectacular display powered by
solar energy
it's like a Beacon of Hope for the
future of our planet right that's pretty
cool
[Music]
thanks shady and for more amazing
climate change beating ideas check out
the sky kids documentary cop 27 six ways
to save our planet available right now
on Sky Kids On Demand and Via our
webpage at first.news forward slash FYI
[Music]
so would you have been brave enough to
have a ride on this new Flying Roller
Coaster well luckily enough you don't
have to be because this is actually fake
news it's just a digitally altered image
and for more on how to spot fake news
and videos like this head to our webpage
and check out our I don't get it
explainer
what would it be like to perform at the
Royal Albert Hall in front of thousands
of people I don't know I think it would
be kind of nerve-wracking but also
really exciting but we've got an
exclusive backstage pass to this year's
youth Broms and met some of the pupils
taking the stage by storm hi I'm
Charlotte and I'm Evie hi I'm Isabel and
we are girls rap Collective and later
today we'll be performing in there this
is the Royal Albert Hall the place where
the pumps happened this is usually a
series of concerts performed by adults
but today it's our turn to shine
here we go standing up everybody
we're just about to do the sound check
and I can't wait
back in January when we first like
discovered each other's talents and how
we all actually enjoy music and we kind
of like just vibed to see put in a beat
and then just putting a b vibe in and
then we came up with one like genre that
we like and that turned out to be like
afro r b draw she started writing our
own songs we started showing them to
like the school and like everyone was a
bit judgmental especially the boys and
so it just shows that you shouldn't
judge someone without knowing what they
can do
[Music]
so us being on stage and us being black
shows that we have that opportunity and
we have that passion and that drive
especially how we're a group of females
as well yeah
being able to write about being black
and the struggles of it it just feels
amazing we're just happy that we've got
given like this opportunity to like
perform in front of 5 000 people that's
just amazing well try me
and it's not just us 3 000 other young
people are performing too check this out
it's quite nerve-wracking because
obviously it's like like a very famous
place and it's like an amazing place for
a musician to go and play
playing with my friends on a stage a
piece that we've worked on for months
and months is going to be so rewarding
you do something like this so early into
being at the choir is just a really
incredible experience to to do something
like performing here at the Royal Albert
Hall where so many other famous people
have performed yeah
it's not long now until we go on stage
and absolutely smash it here
foreign
[Music]
ly we've got some good news about FYI
we've won a bachelor award for our
special edition of the program to help
us all understand about the Ukraine
invasion
bafta stand for the British Academy of
film and television Arts an organization
that supports talent and Rewards program
makers in the UK so this really meant a
lot to all of us and you can still see
our special programs about the war on
Ukraine on our website at first.news
forward slash FYI now we decided to
dedicate this award to the millions of
child refugees fleeing war on conflict
around the world that's it for today see
you next time
[Music]
foreign